[Music]
[Applause]
what we're going to be doing now is
something that is
really dangerous
the village has located an africanized
bee nest africanized bees are called
killer bees
and the deal with killer bees is they
were made by trying to develop a super
honey bee one that is incredibly
productive but a side effect of that and
unintentionally they wound up also
making a hyper aggressive beat
[Music]
killer bees kill people
the warowl work around this
the real genius is this chunk of
smoldering termite nest
oh yeah smoke smokey smoky
we're going to make lots of smoke and
what the smoke does is it messes with
the bees
chemical communication
it basically inhibits those bees the
pheromone that tells the whole hive to
attack
oh yeah that's red
okay let's go
[Music]
after a scramble through the jungle we
reach the nest
just like so yes
[Music]
alan is
busy chopping away getting at the center
of the hive
this is a hollowed-out log
and they're living right in the middle
of it
wild honey provides a vital source of
sweet energy
the world are careful to leave the hive
intact
and they take only what they need we've
gotta work fast before we run out of
light
and smoke
i'm just working like crazy
i gotta keep blowing smoke into this
hole
or they're all gonna come out by the
thousands
that's i'm fired okay i'm coming okay
yeah here you go here yeah one stinging
my leg right now
the bees are getting angry
if they swarm
we're in deadly serious trouble
i need to speed this up
oh they're coming out
oh yeah yeah look at this there's the
hive
there it is there it is
it's a huge huge colony
they have enough honey in there they can
recuperate
ah they're stinging though aye
okay keep chopping
they are stinging me
wow
our killer bee honey heist is at a
critical stage
if it takes much longer
the bees will attack
we're running out of fire we're running
out of smoke
ah
got it
okay we found the honey
the mother lode
that's so much honey
all right let's get out of here let's go
yep
ah that could have gone horribly wrong
and uh and i've never done that before
ever
raided a
killer bee nest
that is really
good it's definitely going to be
a hit back at the village
hmm
[Music]
you